fue una inusual convención nacional
republicana en una ruptura inédita del
código político se llevó a cabo en los
jardines de la casa blanca que es
propiedad del gobierno y no del partido
una reunión rodeada por una multitud sin
máscaras y sin cumplir con el
distanciamiento social esto contrastó
con la convención demócrata en la que yo
vayan pronunció un breve discurso en un
auditorio casi vacío ballena había
descrito la administración de champ como
una oscuridad que se apoderaba del país
así que transite vuelto el golpe
sembrando el miedo ante una victoria de
byd en eeuu la tierra envuelta en
tinieblas es la antorcha que ilumina al
mundo
el presidente también acusó falsamente a
job aiden de querer un confinamiento en
el país y juró que una vacuna contra el
coronavirus estaría disponible a finales
de año a pesar de tener una de las tasas
de mortalidad más altas del mundo
felicitó a su administración por el
manejo de la crisis a ningún
estadounidense
necesitaba un ventilador se le ha negado
lo cual es un milagro
y
es un buen trabajo por el grupo
encabezado por nuestro gran
vicepresidente por favor levántese
joan pelo yo también su propia gestión
antes de la pandemia sobre el empleo y
la economía previo a un tema clave de la
campaña de este año las protestas contra
la violencia policial y el racismo no
mencionado floyd ni a ninguna otra
víctima de la violencia policial por su
nombre pero prometió apoyar a las
fuerzas del orden tenemos que devolverle
el poder a la policía no estará seguro
en la américa de iovine en mi
administración siempre apoyará a los
hombres y mujeres que apliquen la ley
el presidente agitó su discurso
recurriendo al caos de lo que él llama
la izquierda radical de joe biden y
durante toda su intervención se presentó
como el único que puede garantizar la
prosperidad en el país